if I'm tired today if I wake up in the
morning it's 4:30 and I'm like man I am
wicked tired and I don't feel like doing
this today what I do is I note it down
in my head like okay you were tired then
I go do it anyways and if I'm tired the
next day if the next day I say the same
thing then I'm like okay you know what
that's two days in a row your workout
was weak I'm paying attention and like
okay guess what you need you need a
little downtime that's that's the way I
do it I won't accept like the one thing
in the world I'll procrastinate is
procrastination thank you if I want to
take a day off it's like okay the other
thing about this is is you know this
idea of quitting right this idea of
quitting and never quitting and people
can confuse that because if I'm in
charge or if I'm in charge of a squad
and it's like hey we're gonna we're
gonna go assault that that bunker on the
top of the hill okay there's a bunker on
top of hill with a machine gun in it my
squad we're gonna go assault it if we
charge uphill to an elevated position I
know there's a lot of vets in here
what's gonna happen okay yeah two or
three of us get killed like that you
know what we never quit go again two or
three more guys died go again everyone's
dead
did I never quit I never quit did I fail
my mission yes I did so you have to keep
track of like what's my long-term goal
my long-term goal isn't to take that
machine-gun nest it's to win the war so
if you're doing something on a daily
basis and you start feeling casualties
you need to assess yourself and say you
know you can have a business idea and
I've talked to a bunch of people like
this they got that business idea and
their mindsets I'm never gonna quit well
then they're running out of money not
just money for their business money for
their family and it's like okay hey if
you've got it what what adjustments can
you make strategically cuz the pattern
that you're going right now if you keep
charging up that hill with that business
the way you are everyone dies if you say
you know what time for tactical retreat
time for me to step back time
for me to call up some firepower to come
and help drop some bombs on this target
or get some fire support whatever the
case may be so keep that in mind as well
need motivation 10 we believe nation
he's gentle wooly and here's my take on
his top ten booth success volume seven
enjoy rule number two
go on the offense sometimes overwhelmed
there's just too many things going on
and you start to feel like you're
getting beat like you're losing the
battle and when that happens to me what
I like to do is I like to go on the
hardcore offense so I just call it a
sprint I will sprint hard I'll I'll take
the things that I have to get done for
work and I will just pile them up and I
will work two or three 12 16 18 hour
days to get caught up it's a lot better
for me to suffer hard for three days and
grind then to suffer the continual
burden that's weighing on your back for
months on end don't let that happen
if you get a little bit behind and you
need to get caught up hit the turbo
button go hard for three or four days
get yourself where you need to be rule
number three make your life better than
a movie Anthony Bourdain obviously he
was about as successful as as anyone
could be I mean he was a successful guy
in so many aspects and yet and yet he
killed himself he said in this book I
wanted adventures I wanted to go up the
num liver to the heart of darkness in
Cambodia I wanted to ride out into a
desert on Camelback sand and dunes in
every direction eat whole roasted lamb
with my fingers I wanted to kick snow
off my boots in a Mafia nightclub in
Russia I wanted to play with automatic
weapons in phenom penh recapture the
past in a small boy stur village in
france step into a seedy neon-lit
vu Korea in rural Mexico
I wanted to run roadblocks in the middle
of the night blowing past angry militia
with a handful of hurled marble packs
[Music]
experience fear excitement wonder I
wanted kicks the kind of melodramatic
thrills and chills I've yearned for
since childhood the kind of adventure
I'd found as a little boy in the pages
of my Tintin comic books I wanted to see
the world and I wanted the world to be
just like the movies
that's what Anthony Bourdain said just
like the movies but you know what to me
the world is not like the movies the
movies aren't real they don't exist but
you do and life this life is it's better
than any movie there is movies are
supposed to provoke emotion they're
supposed to make you feel something but
I have a better idea go out into the
world and actually feel it go feel joy
and love and triumph and rapture and
ecstasy and glory go feel those things
and you know with those feelings there
will be other feelings as well there
will be
sorrow and pain and sadness and
desolation and suffering there'll be all
those feelings too but you know what
[Music]
that's okay that's okay take both sides
feel all that that's what life is those
feelings those emotions those eyes and
those lows those are life rule number
four take ownership and as I talk about
taking ownership of things you know when
I get done talking to people
I'll get done and someone will come up
to me and they'll say hey you know I I
really liked what you said about about
ownership now if I could just get my
team to take ownership we'd be good to
go and then someone else would come up
to me and say hey hey I really liked
what you said about ownership that was
really cool man I appreciate it and I I
really hope my co-workers heard you
because if they will just take ownership
we'd be good to go and then someone will
come up to me and say hey man I really
like that whole thing about extreme
ownership and I really hope that my boss
was listening because if I could just
get my boss to take ownership we'd be
good to go and then I always have to
make it crystal clear to them that I'm
not talking about their team and I'm not
talking about their co-workers and I'm
not talking their boss I'm talking about
you I'm talking about you the only
person that you can actually control you
that's who has to take ownership that's
who has to step up own everything and we
also if you want to learn how to build
confidence like Jaco and other
entrepreneurs chicken my 64 confidence
series to link in the description below
people want to know how to
the laziness and they will know how to
stop the procrastination rule number
five leave when I go up to origin and I
get to go in the factory and see the
people that that are working hard and
their work hard every day every day and
they put their heart and soul into
making these products that's that's an
unbelievable thing to say and it got
taken away you know that got taken away
and to be in this situation now where
we're literally able to bring it back
that actually needs something we're not
taking our foot off the gas
we're gonna go harder we're gonna push
more we're going to get involved in more
it's gonna be a grind there's risk you
know what we're putting our money into
by machines that are covered in dust
because we believe and if you believe in
something you take the risk that's what
you do and that's what we're doing and
you don't want we're gonna win rule
number six seize your opportunities and
when I was getting ready to retire a guy
that I knew was a friend of mine he was
the CEO of a company and he said hey can
you come and talk to my executives you
know about about combat leadership and I
said you know sure I'll do it you friend
of mine so I went and did it and I don't
know what he thought I was gonna talk
about but when I got done he came up to
me and said I want you to do this for
every division that I have in my company
and I said well I'm retiring and I don't
know and he said I'll give you money and
I said how much and we worked it out and
he ended up talking to every division
that he had at his company and at one of
those divisional meetings the CEO of the
parent company was there and when I got
done you know briefing about leadership
that CEO came up to me and said hey I
want you to talk to the CEOs of all my
companies and you know he owned 45 or 50
companies and from there I went and
talked to those CEOs and the next thing
you know I I had a I had a new job you
know and I didn't get to retire like I
had planned rule number seven
study leadership when I was a young I
was I enlisted in the Navy out of high
school that was the youngest guy in my
first I was the youngest and most June
guy in my first two SEAL platoons and
what I was doing was I was looking at my
leaders and I was watching him and I was
paying attention to what they were doing
and I was paying attention to why we
liked this guy and why we wanted to
follow this guy but why we didn't like
this guy we didn't want to follow him
the biggest characteristic I notice of
that was guys that were humble we wanted
to follow guys that were arrogant we
didn't want to follow but that was one
of many many little lessons and I paid
attention to once I moved into a
leadership position I knew that all
those guys they were watching me they
were paying attention to me and I had to
think about the way that they were gonna
react to what I was doing and I knew
that my job was to lead these guys and I
knew that they were taking notes and
they were monitoring and they were
testing and if I was arrogant they
weren't gonna follow me and if I thought
I knew everything they weren't gonna
follow me I'm not saying I couldn't be
confident because yeah you have to be
confident there's a balanced dichotomy
leadership right but you have to pay
attention to those around you to the
people that work for you the people that
work that they did you work for and you
monitor what they're doing and you
process what you would follow and what
you wouldn't and then you emulate that
that's what I did that's what I'm most
importantly still doing today
be willing to do whatever it takes I
work with a lot of different Millennials
in a lot of different industries they
work hard and they get after a nursery
successful
Millennials in the military have been
doing a great job so to think that
society's gotten harder now on people I
don't really buy into that life's hard
you want to be successful you're gonna
have to work hard it's not just gonna
show up you're gonna have to dig you
have to wake up early and stay up late
it's the way it works you gotta be
willing to do things that your enemy is
not willing to do and your competitor is
not willing to do rule number nine get
up early yes I wake up early yes I wake
up at 4:30 in the morning guess what you
got 24 hours in a day the earlier you
get up the more you can take advantage
of those hours the more you get up
before the enemy or your competitor or
actually in some cases your family and
friends the more stuff you can get done
before they all start bothering you what
you should do if you want to start
waking up early is start waking up early
you figure out what that time is for you
and then you start waking up at that
time now if you wake up and it's earlier
than you normally wake up by the end of
the day guess what you'll be a little
bit more tired and then you can go to
bed a little bit earlier and you
continue with that pattern until you get
a good fixated time of going to bed and
waking up the other piece of this is on
the weekends people think oh great it's
the weekend now I can sleep in negative
don't sleep in on the weekends when you
sleep in in the weekends you know on
Saturday you sleep in until 6:30 in the
morning well now you're not tired at
night so you stay up a little bit later
and then on Sunday you sleep in until
8:00 and by the time Monday morning
rolls around you stayed up until
midnight and now you don't feel like
waking up early so get up early and get
up early everyday and get a workout in
take care of your health I guarantee
your day will go better give it a shot
get some and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is stop
lying to yourself we lie to ourselves we
don't tell ourselves the way things
really are
when we do that and then we can't fix
our problems if we can't fix our
problems will knock on the proof so we
have to be truthful to ourselves
you have to stop rationalizing stop
making excuses stop delude yourself
little water down assessments of where
you're really at tell yourself the truth
so that you can get where you want to go
you should be when you do what you know
you should do when you pay attention to
the little things when you implement
discipline true and unflinching and
unmitigated discipline in your life when
you stop trying to find a sweat this
solution
when you look for weaknesses to work on
and all that starts when you stop lying
to yourself
[Applause]
tell yourself the truth about where you
are so you can make sure you are in the
right place and if you're not with the
right place that you can get yourself on
the path to get there
discipline the path of hard work and
[Music]
I'm at a special bonus clip from jock on
how to build self discipline that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
somewhere the three-point landing
questions time just watching the video
guys taking action your life for
business here we go question number one
where are you lying to yourself that
must end today number two how can you
commit to getting up earlier every day
for the next week and number three which
three leaders will you commit to
studying this month to become a better
leader yourself where does discipline
come from pretty soon every comments
discipline comes from within
it's a
force
now sir of course you could have
discipline imposed on you by some person
like like a drill instructor
like that self-help
b-but the reality is that type of
discipline isn't the real type of
discipline that we're talking about that
discipline isn't as strong it won't
survive
what you need is self discipline how
self discipline comes from the self it
comes from you it comes from when you
make a decision to be disciplined when
you make a decision to be better when
you make a decision to do more and to be
more self discipline cause when you
decide that you're gonna make a mark on
the world and if you think that you're
not disciplined or you can't discipline
it's because you haven't
decided to be disciplined it's because
you haven't needed that discipline yet
[Music]
so make this
discipline the huge quality that we
every aspect of your life
[Music]
and stronger and smarter and faster
and rooster
Adelman confer
[Applause]
if you want more jockle willing
motivation go check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
self-help or self management or
self-improvement I don't really like
what those words have come to mean these
days